(sirens wailing)
(tense rhythmic music)
(seagulls screeching)
(birds chirping)
(gentle music)
Humans are amazing.
I mean, there's so much beauty in humanity.
We often hear narratives that are highlighting
all the horrible things that are going on in our world.
And as we know, we are powerful creators
and where we put our attention is what expands.
And I think that there's wisdom and power
and intelligence in highlighting the beauty of humanity,
because there's a lot more beauty than what is considered.
Wealth is the company you keep.
(rhythmic upbeat music)
Greetings, Podcastlandia!
Proud to let you guys know
that we are back with the beautiful, the wise, the erudite,
Julie Piatt SriMati,
spiritualist, expert, vegan, cheese empresario,
entrepreneur, culinary genius,
bestselling cookbook author,
community leader, podcaster, musician, mother ark,
and my partner, not in crime, but in all things.
How are you?
Ah, thanks, Rich Roll.
I'm great. Thanks for-
Did I cover the list?
I'm in awe in your poetry
and your ability to express me in new and expanded ways.
Ooh, continue.
(laughing) Thank you.
Continue with that thought.
It's so beautiful, thank you so much.
When was the last time you were on?
I don't, it's been a while.
It's been a minute, right?
Yeah, it's about time.
And actually, the studio has kind of come around
a little bit more since you were last year.
It's incredible, this is just such an amazing experience.
I feel so blessed and excited, it's very cool.
Well, you kick this whole thing off with episode one
back in that cavernous warehouse in Kauai,
it's come a long way since then.
But in most respects, in the most important respects,
I think the show has maintained the sensibility
that we initiated back then.
And I'm happy to have you back to continue the conversation
that started on this show
in the fall of 2012.
So, we're actually
like just weeks away from the nine year anniversary
of this whole affair.
That's crazy.
I was remembering that this morning
'cause it's a rainy day finally in Southern California.
And I was wondering how long it's been, so nine years.
Yeah, we started it in November,
I don't remember the exact date.
I think it was like mid-November.
I think the island fever had set in about week three.
I was starting to get itchy and antsy
and feeling disconnected from people
and the universe and scratch the itch to try this thing out
without any sense of where it would go.
And here we are.
And it's amazing. it really is amazing.
I think it's also really profound
that the spiritual energy of Kauai is within this podcast.
It is the energy that
created or participated in the manifestation,
(clears throat) excuse me,
as did all of the food journey as well.
So we were landlocked without really friends.
We weren't really welcomed in Kauai by the community.
And we found ourselves sort of
staying in our three 30-foot yurts
and I had a test kitchen
and then I just started creating food,
and that's most of the recipes in the plant power way.
And then you were like, "I'm gonna go crazy.
"We're starting a podcast."(laughs)
I know.
I mean, shout out to Chris Jabe,
who invited us to live on his incredible property.
Yes, Chris.
Common ground, he since sold that property,
but we were living, we've told the story many times,
so I don't want to linger too long on it,
but for those of you that are a little bit newer,
we lived on this extraordinary property
on the north shore of Kauai.
It had been a mango farm,
and Chris who owned it, was looking to figure out
how to leverage this extraordinary place
for broader purposes.
And for some reason,
he thought that we could be helpful in that regard.
Thank God he did, it was the first time--
We were so broke at the time,
he threw us a lifeline.
He's like, come out to Kauai and live with me
and we'll hang out and try to figure out what to do here.
And we were like, okay.
And before we knew it, like in a very short period of time,
we had essentially relocated,
thinking that we were gonna lose our house
'cause we couldn't pay our bills,
and he kept us afloat.
And that became the crucible,
like the incubator for so many beautiful things.
And so, Really Chris J was very instrumental
in the direction, the trajectory of our lives.
It's unbelievable what an influence he had
in ways that I'm sure he can barely appreciate
in terms of being a catalyst
for everything that we've birthed.
And I think the lesson in there is that you never know,
like people will come into your life
and gently kind of nudge you in one direction or the other,
that then over time,
it only becomes evident like in the rear view mirror,
like what an impact those people have.
And I think we're all visited with
some form or another of individuals like that.
Makes a profound impact,
but I think it's related to,
I just want to tell a little bit more about that story,
because it's very relevant to how I'm interacting
with the creation of food right now.
And at the point in time that Chris came into our lives,
our house had been put in foreclosure,
and I was sort of out of my ability to stall anymore.
And I was very devastated,
came home and told all you guys,
I was like we're gonna lose the house,
in like 30 days it's gonna be gone.
So I came home and I was just,
I had one of those moments of feeling sort of lost
and disconnected from spirituality and God
and like, how could this be happening?
And I remember a Saul David Raye,
who's an amazing yoga teacher in the LA area,
he reached out and he hired me.
He said, "SriMati, will you cook for my Thai yoga retreat?"
And he said, you know, "I can pay you pretty well."
And so I remember leaving, and I just told you,
I said, "There is no way
"that we are being moved out of this house
"without an opportunity.
"It's impossible with the amount of heart
"and presence and how much we had gone through
"and how bonded we were and committed
"to really serving our heart."
And so I remember going up there
just feeling completely in a state of,
I don't know, like I just don't know anything,
like if this is happening,
I was downing all of my instincts.
And so I just decided to literally
put all of my energy into preparing food
for this Thai yoga retreat.
And I, maybe one of the few times that I was single focus
because I do so many things,
but I really stepped into this as a sort of Seva service.
And the food became activated
with something that was beyond my ability to create food.
And I had people weeping when they were eating my pie
and they were leaving Saul's retreat
to stay with me in the kitchen.
And he was joking with me saying like,
"What are you doing to my students?
"Like they just want to be with you."
And so I remember he was very generously said,
"Please invite Rich and the kids up to the final dinner."
And I remember you walked in,
it was up at Bill's place up in Santa Barbara.
Casa Blanca?
No, that's not it.
Casa Barranca, that was it.
Yeah, yeah, I remember that very well.
Yeah, remember that place,
it was like a really cool sort of art deco sort of place.
Anyway.
And you walked in and you said, have you read your emails?
And I said, no.
And you said, go read your email right now.
And I went and read my email.
And Chris J had replied to an email
that I had sent him two years prior.
And he said, I want to speak to you and Rich
I'm halfway through the book
and we wanna meet.
And 10 days later, he was sitting in our living room
having a meeting with all of us.
So it was a very sort of profound demonstration
about how, when you step into devotion at that level
and abandon your personalities, ideas and trajectories,
just how beautiful life can be.
Yeah there's many layers to this idea of surrender, right?
So one of the lines in finding Ultra is
that when your heart is true,
the universe will conspire to support you.
And I believe that,
and I've seen that play out in so many people's lives.
And I felt like when I put finding ultra out
that my heart was true and the universe would conspire
to somehow figure out a way to support us in this mission
and nothing was happening, right?
The phone was not ringing.
There was no money coming in.
We were unable to pay our bills.
And when Saul called you,
it was like, yes, I will do that.
Like, I'll do anything.
And when Chris said, come out to Kauai,
we said, yes, we had no other options.
But also it was like, okay,
we're just giving ourselves over to work wherever
and however we're being directed.
And I just remember moving into those yurts on this farm
and thinking like, we may never see our house again
and perhaps we're just gonna be living in these yurts now.
(laughing)
Like that's it, like now we live in Kauai,
you know, I don't know what's gonna happen tomorrow.
Like this sense of completely letting go
of any idea or attachment to
your sense of expectations or outcomes,
but that is a practice of devotion in and of itself right?
We could've never known
that that would be a trigger point
to lead us in these other directions.
And certainly I would've preferred
the timeline to look differently.
And I had no, like, it wasn't my plan,
I don't know about you,
that we were gonna go live in yurts.
Like I had a whole other agenda and idea
of how this would play out,
but the letting go, which feels like giving up
is really an act of strength.
And so reframing how you approach setbacks and obstacles
is I think a really instructive lesson
that helps me even now, when we face obstacles
or things aren't going the way that we would like
to just be like present with what is happening
and detached from the direction that it's leading you,
because you simply do not know.
Yeah and when the adversity or the constriction
it's like you felt you were going crazy,
you were like, I got to get off this island.
I'm gonna go crazy, like I hate it.
Well, first of all let me just say, like, it's beautiful
and I love, there's a lot of great
I don't wanna be like panning Kauai,
but it was challenging.
We loved Kauai.
Yes, because we were far away from our friends.
We were in a new place.
It is difficult.
Like there's a big difference
between visiting Hawaii on vacation and living there.
Complete.
And there's a very heightened energy
that exists on the north shore of Kauai.
And I think it is fair to say
that it's not exactly the most welcoming place
in that the people that live there are very protective of it
and protective of their kind of respective five times
and there does tend to be
a little bit of a zero sum perspective.
Like, this is my thing you're over here,
just so you know, like it was different, right?
And I think you have to pay your dues
and you have to really establish,
like we're here for the longterm
and we mean business.
And I think we were coming from a place
of relative uncertainty, but also with open hearts
and so it was like,
hey, how come it's so hard to make friends here?
Oh it was completely different than I imagined
because Kauai is probably
my dearest spiritual point on the planet.
I've had, you know, miraculous experiences
on the beaches there and secret beach
and been there like seven or eight times.
So I thought it was gonna be shelter.
I thought it was gonna be this embrace,
this loving embrace.
And the land did lovingly embrace us,
it's just the community didn't (laughs) so
it was just different but I was goi--
But It made us go it turned,
it was great because it forced us to turn inward
and focus on the things that we can control
and what we can create.
So you went into this,
there was one yurt that was a huge kitchen.
And you went in there and just said,
I'm gonna make recipes.
And of course that led to the plant power way
and the plant power way Italia, ultimately after that,
and also this cheese is nuts and SriMu,
which we have in front of us right here,
that we're gonna talk about it all started there.
And the podcast was a response to me
feeling disconnected
and feeling like I needed another creative project
to invest my time and energy.
And so that's what happened.
That's right.
And so in the constriction,
if you become present and engaged
in the present moment of what's in front of you,
the constriction ends up not being the negative thing
that you thought at the start,
but it's in fact the alchemy or the friction
that's needed to produce the expansion.
That's the lesson.
Before we get too deep into this,
I do have an announcement that I want to make.
This past year,
I think it's fair to say
has been a challenging year for everybody.
More so for some that than others,
but also a magical show for,
I mean a magical year
for this show for myself, for our family.
I've had some amazing guests on the podcast.
I've gleaned a plethora of critical,
important lessons from those conversations.
But at the core, this show, the focus of this show is,
and has always been how to best serve you.
And by you, I mean the listener, the audience,
how it benefits you, orientates you, meets your needs,
how it inspires you to reframe your vision of family,
of work, of sense of self,
and how it can act as an agent of change
in your own personal evolution.
So with that,
we have this idea here, my team,
everybody at the studio
to explore a bit of an experiment with you guys,
the listeners, if you are willing to participate.
And what that means is I'd like you to consider
sharing with me your personal journey of transformation,
how the podcast and its myriad of guests has inspired you,
what you've learned, what you've practiced,
what you've implemented or shared with others along the way.
And my team and I will then take all of that
and compile a portion of those submissions
into a special future episode
that we wanna create.
And the origin of this idea is
really just the absolutely mind-bending quantity
of emails that we receive every single day.
You guys, the listeners have been writing in
to share your many empowering tales
of perseverance through adversity
and new beginnings
and sobriety and stepping into new identities,
all the successes, the losses, the tears, the triumphs,
the heartfelt stories of real life,
epiphanies and transformations.
And I think there's something really potent and important
about your journey that others can benefit from hearing.
So the idea is that learning is a communal act,
it doesn't happen in isolation,
and this podcast is really a conduit to that.
So I'd like to share stories like yours
with other listeners.
If you guys are willing to call in
and leave a voice message
about your journey of transformation,
because we want to know about it.
So to do that, if you're up for it
and I'd love it if you would indulge me,
leave a voicemail at (805) 421-0057,
and just share your story, it can be as long as you want,
as well as the wisdom that you've gleaned along the way
from the show, what you've built into your life from it.
And I think your message could very well be aired
in this future episode that we're working on.
Again, so the number is (805) 421-0057.
And I look forward to hearing from all you guys.
What do you think about that idea?
I just absolutely love that, it's gonna be extraordinary.
So can't wait for that.
Yeah, because humans are amazing.
That's right.
Which is one of the things
that we wanted to talk about today.
Yeah, we wanted to just say
very plainly, humans are amazing (laughs).
Is that it?
Expound.
No, just because
I really feel, and you really feel,
I mean, there's so much beauty in humanity.
I mean, humans are just,
they're all individual and unique and resilient and creative
and courageous and empathic and loving and feeling.
And we often hear narratives
that are tearing down the negative
or sort of highlighting all the horrible things
that are going on in our world.
And as we know we are powerful creators
and where we put our attention is what expands.
And so I feel that through this timeout
that we've all gone through in the last couple of years,
we've even come to appreciate our friends
and our community even deeper,
not only are our close friends,
but also our extended communities,
even on social media or through the podcast
or through different mentorship groups
or the SriMu community.
And I think that there's wisdom and power and intelligence
in highlighting the beauty of humanity,
because there's a lot more beauty
than what is brought up for review or to be considered.
And I think it's human sort of the human tendency
to feel justified, pointing out everything that's wrong.
And then there's something within the personality or the ego
that feels like, oh, you know, see I'm right.
How wrong is that?
And this is so wrong and this is so wrong.
And so I just think it's a wonderful time.
We're all alive in a body.
Hopefully if you're listening to this podcast
and you're breathing, you have the privilege of being alive,
the privilege of being connected to this podcast
and just to highlight the beauty of humanity
and how all of us have something so meaningful
to bring and offer and share.
Yeah, wealth is the company you keep
and humans are amazing.
And I think right now,
if you're watching the news
or you're scrolling on social media,
you get the distinct impression
that we are extraordinarily polarized,
that there is this breakdown
in our ability to communicate in a healthy way.
There is this division that's being exacerbated
by various narratives out there.
And we're rewarded for sharing our angst
and our disagreements
and for tearing people down
rather than trying to rise each other up.
Not to say that all of those things aren't true
and they don't exist
because that is part and parcel of our culture right now,
which makes it confusing, I think.
But in my experience when I'm out in the world
or when I travel or I'm walking down the street,
or I call a friend,
these are not the experiences that I'm having
one-on-one or when I greet people,
like I am nourished by
being in the world and sharing honestly
with the people that I'm close with and meeting new people,
like there's such a gap between my lived experience
and my digital experience.
And I think it's a reminder to tip that scale a little bit
and try to live your life a little bit more analog.
And I'm really, you know,
connecting with this in a bit of a more profound way
than I have historically.
And I think that's a result of the pandemic on some level
and being forced to isolate for so long.
And now that we're able to kind of be in the world
a little bit more than we were,
six or eight or 12 months ago,
I'm just much more appreciative
of those interpersonal interactions
and relationships that I have
than perhaps I was prior to the pandemic.
I've always been somebody who
is fine being alone.
I like the silence I need that
quiet to recharge
and never really appreciated
how important being with other people is.
And I went into the pandemic thinking I'm gonna be fine.
And ultimately, like so many
ended up profoundly kind of lonely,
in that isolation.
And so now that we can kind of
be in the world a little bit more,
I've made this commitment to myself
to really engage my friendships
a little bit better than I have in the past.
And just say yes to things that ordinarily
I might say no to, or shun off,
because I have my way of doing things like with training.
Like I like to train alone
and like, I don't really like want to go with anyone else,
but now I'm saying yes
to communal group kind of training activities.
I've been going to Larry and Gabby's house
and doing the pool workout,
which isn't really
traditionally part of the way
that I approach my physical routine or my training,
but I've been so nourished
just by doing physical things with other people.
And it's just made me a happier person to do that.
Definitely .
I think turning 55,
like my birthday the past week.
Happy birthday.
Thank you, have a few thoughts on that.
Please share.
Some of which I shared on Instagram the other day.
I mean, mainly gratitude.
I mean, we talked earlier about
a little bit about the arc that we've been on.
I mean, now we're in this very privileged place
where I get to wake up every day
and essentially do things that excite me.
I never thought that my life would look like this,
and yet here we are.
So I'm profoundly grateful to be able to have this vocation
and to indulge like my curiosity,
and to be able to share space and time with people
that inspire me in so many ways.
And to leverage that for my own personal learning
and then share it with the world.
I mean, it's like the greatest thing ever.
And as I shared on Instagram last week,
like if this is it,
people always say to me, what's next,
or what are you building?
Or what's the vision, or what's the dream.
And, you know, I have ambitions.
And as I said on Instagram,
there are roads that are still untraveled
and things that I wanna express and do.
But if it's never more than this, like it's good.
And if I was to not wake up tomorrow morning,
like it's a life well lived.
So I feel very grateful,
but I also want to invest more deeply in my friendships.
I think that's something that I've overlooked in the past
and something I wanna pay more attention to
because wealth is the company you keep
and I've been doing that and it's been great,
and I feel like I'm in a much better place
than I was last year at this time.
So I feel good.
It's beautiful to see.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment
to talk to you about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and legumes
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however,
without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly,
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised, I'm proud to say
is The PlantPower Meal Planner,
are affordable, all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up,
visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership.
When you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff,
people for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com promo code RRHEALTH
for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
What else about humans being amazing?
(laughs)
I mean, I think one of the,
one of the great opportunities that we have
is to exercise the will to connect
in the phase of forced separation.
When you see agendas that are operating in our world
that are seeking to separate, we have a choice.
We can find a neutrality
and understanding that everything in life is sacred.
Everything comes from divine,
even the things that you consider dark
or the things that you don't agree with?
And if we can sort of relax into that direct connection
with our own source consciousness,
we can stop comparing and trying to analyze a situation
into an intellectual place where we feel safe with it.
And so the work is in the face of separation,
can we be neutral and open and in on wonder
and just allow all things
and it's more of a, not this or that, or either or,
it's about a yes and.
Both things can be true from a certain perspective.
And life is full of billions
of different kinds of life forms that are completely unique.
So how could one opinion or one lens
know that it is the way for all things at all times?
I think it's just the fear of the personality
that wants to create a box that gives some certainty.
And I think many of us know and realize now
there is no certainty
and there really wasn't ever certainty in that way,
but we had things sort of in a place
where we could be in that illusion.
So it really is what you and I just described
is in the constriction, coming into the present moment,
activating neutrality,
understanding that everything comes from a sacred place.
It is all part of the play.
And we can find a way
into transformation by going into the separation,
rather than running away from it or turning away from it.
We can have the courage to go into the experience
with that neutrality.
And if we're lucky, we're probably gonna learn something
or expand or soften
or experience something that maybe we never imagined.
This is always been true,
but everything feels so heightened right now.
And the stakes are high
and people are on edge and practicing
what you just spoke of, becomes much more challenging.
We're all very easily triggered.
And we all have our cognitive biases
and our respective worldviews.
And this has been a challenge for me.
I mean, you mentioned like resisting the impulse
to default to your intellectual realization
of an issue based on past experiences or history.
And I find myself doing that
and we've had many conversations about that.
Like how can I approach dissonance
from a perspective of openness and empathy?
And it requires a lot,
like it is a very challenging practice
to apply in real world scenario.
That is true,
and that is what is being asked of us right now,
because it's not letting up, like we are transforming.
It's not going back to the way it was.
And so we are being required to expand our ability
and to do more than what we normally would do.
And many of these patterns are just defaults.
It's not even the real you that's doing it.
It's just a pattern of sort of a habit in a way.
And so you can choose a different habit.
You can choose a different act, a different emotion,
a different state of being.
It always sort of is surprising to me
with the way that we are in our humanity,
full of amazing things and full of faults
or things that sort of are not as expanded.
And how does one person feels so justified,
judging another system?
Like so absolutely.
I mean, the more we know when we explore a spirituality
and the nature of life, the more we know we don't know.
So can we be in a state of not knowing and be okay with it
and then activate the natural,
deep human connection of unconditional love,
just love and allowing all things
and understanding like much in our experience
of our relationship, when you were eating,
In and Out burger and in Starbucks with,
three ad shots in it,
that catalytic point where I just realized
that I had no right to impose my idea
of your life into your experience,
even though from a perspective you were less healthy,
you were struggling, you weren't happy.
Still, even in that experience,
that's your choice of experience.
And this is really the moment
that catalyze this entire play that we're in right now,
it was the release of me being attached
to how you had to eat or live or be in order to be loved,
or even viewed as an emanation of God consciousness.
Another piece to that
is this idea that you cannot and should not,
well should is a challenging word,
but you really can't save someone from their suffering.
And in certain situations you shouldn't
because the suffering is the engine for growth ultimately,
and that's a tricky
thing to understand and embrace,
particularly when you're a parent.
I was just gonna say that, yeah.
You know what I mean?
Definitely.
Like we all want to save our kids from hardship.
Ever anything, anything that could hurt them.
Or if you see your child suffering
and you just wanna make it go away.
And there's a powerlessness to that.
But I think that powerlessness is also a reminder
that suffering is part of life.
And
it applies to this cultural moment
that we're in right now in a profound way,
in the sense that prior to the pandemic
things kind of went a certain way
and there was a sensibility
that we're almost in this post history phase
where we're not gonna meet obstacles in our life
and things are just gonna continue
to go along their merry way.
But that's not how life is,
and that's not how life has ever been.
And it's not about arriving at a place
where you're gonna be liberated from hardship and obstacles.
It's about how you develop the wherewithal
and the strength and the fortitude
and the perspective to be able to roll with all of that
and learn from it
because we're here to have those experiences to grow,
to pass on the wisdom
and ultimately, kind of transcend those past experiences
to become more fully formed,
integrated, authentic, actualized humans.
Yeah definitely,
and I think that the want to stop someone from their demise
or from something that they're experiencing
is also mixing your energy in their life event.
And if you understand that,
so now that we're parents sort of on the other spectrum
and our kids are grown,
pretty much grown up to a certain degree,
when they're young, you're creating this life
and I definitely think in this generation
we have parents who are very engaged,
very present, very involved.
I mean, people that just really have given their entire life
and heart and soul to their children,
to make sure that they have a nurturing experience of life.
And then what happens is
because the human wants the contrast,
whatever it is that you provided,
you're gonna be rejected for what you provided.
And that becomes the narrative,
that becomes the constriction, the thing to push up against.
And so if we can remember to,
when we were going through our immense financial collapse,
it was really a nine year process,
like a year down and then seven in the trenches
and then a year out,
I just wanted someone to tell me that they trusted me
and they believed in me,
there are very few people that could hold me in that light.
Some very amazing individuals who were like,
no, no, no, I see you.
I see you in your expansion.
I see it for you.
But what we do normally
is we point out everything that's wrong.
And we focus on the thing that we're worried about
and then praying or worrying
is praying for what you don't want to happen.
So you're in fact adding to the burden of that individual
by being afraid of that individual's trajectory.
And so, again, it's not easy,
especially challenging as a parent,
but we have to remember,
we have the opportunity to remember
what about providing a feeling, even if it's silent,
even if it's in a prayer or in a ceremony
or a moment that you're just like, I trust you.
I know you are a divine emanation of this sacred life
and you're in your human experience.
And so I'm just gonna hold that for you,
and I'm gonna try to remove any drugs or knives,
I mean, there's still another human element to that,
but just this ultimate trust of really understanding
that every human being will have their experience.
And we've shared many times between us and on this show,
you know, I mean, it's a lot of what your show is.
It's the adversity that catalyzes the trajectory
and oftentimes in life
the beings that really have a quite expansive journey
have a very like extreme spectrum,
like taking like Charlie Chaplin,
he was an orphan on the streets and his mom was insane
and look at what that being did in his life.
But usually when it's that big of a trajectory,
there's an equal dark trajectory
or intense trajectory that creates this friction.
It's challenging for me.
I mean, I grew up, you know, you spoke about worry,
being a prayer for what you don't want to have happen.
Like I grew up in a household where
worry was like very in the forefront (laughs)
of my upbringing,
along with a fair dose of enmeshments and expectations,
and things like that,
that have created this sort of imprint on me
and programming that I see myself repeating at times
when I'm not mindful and present.
And what's so interesting about that is
despite all the work that I've done on myself
and this tremendous amount of growth that I've experienced
through really devoting myself
to transcending past experiences,
I still find myself repeating these patterns
like, yes, the contrast
the child will want to define themselves
in opposition to whatever pain point
they identify as a childhood trauma
that reared up in their upbringing,
by dent of their parents.
I'm no exception to that.
I was raised in a certain way
and I'm like, I'm not gonna be like that,
and I'm not gonna raise my kids like this.
And I love my parents, it's not about that,
but despite all of that,
now at 55, I'll find myself saying things
that my mother would say
or indulging in an emotional landscape
that is very characteristic of her DNA.
And it's you who will often say
you're doing that thing again.
And it's very unconscious.
So the point being like,
it doesn't matter how much work you've done,
these things are so deeply imprinted on us
that it requires like a tremendous amount of awareness
and consciousness to catch it when it's happening.
And to have that moment of pause or repose
to kind of course correct when it percolates up.
Well there's nothing like a child's dark night journey
that can catalyze more evolution within the parent.
(laughing)
And that's part of the one of the things
that you always say is like, our kids are here,
they're our teachers,
our evolution is being catalyzed by their experiences.
And just when you thought you had it all figured out
and got really comfortable,
then they start pushing those button
and you're just like, what is going on?
Yeah, 'cause I'm like, I'm gonna be the cool parent.
I'm gonna be up to everything that's been going on.
No, no, we're not cool.
We're totally not cool (laughs).
You will not be cool
and you will not be tapped into whatever it is
that they feel is interesting or important.
And it should be that way and that's awesome.
Yeah, exactly. I mean, they need to differentiate.
That's just the way that it is,
and it won't be like that forever
because I really do think it does matter
all of the other present moments
where as parents, we were there and really did care
and really did our best, you know.
By holding that neutrality.
It's not for the weary, I mean, it's intense.
We definitely, in the pandemic,
we had some major stuff going on in our living spaces.
(laughs)
As I'm sure most families did.
Well and also I just wanted to be sort of transparent
also in my relationship as well.
I mean, the narrative of the outer world
made its way into our relationship
and there were patterns that were running
and trying to separate us
and this sort of like,
you know I think it was just in the early sort of months
or whatever when we were trying to get a handle
on what was going on.
And I also think that it's sort of a masculine tendency
to want to handle things.
Like I'm gonna get this handled
and I'm gonna assess it.
And I'm gonna tell you what's up
and that was really difficult and it was painful.
And I think that speaking this in many, many families
were split down the middle.
And luckily in our case,
we have a good enough foundation
that we were in a lot of love
and we were able to stay neutral
until the landmines had been disarmed
and we could come closer together.
But it's been a very, very intense moment for all of us.
And so again on your birthday
you and I went out for a date
and we had some really beautiful time together.
But the main communication of that
was I wanted to speak to you.
I didn't want to write you a card.
I wanted to speak to you
and I wanted to tell you
how I feel about our life and our relationship
and about what we've experienced together,
understanding that if either one of us
transitioned at any point, and we were no longer here,
I didn't want to leave that, all of that unsaid.
I wanted to make sure that I went deeper into you
rather than moving away.
Yeah, it was beautiful.
It was needed and deeply appreciated.
And I think as a couple, we've been together since 2000
and together like almost 21 years at this point,
I can't remember when we got married,
but I always just think about when we first got together
2003.
I think.
2003, July 12th.
Right, you were pregnant with Mathis, right?
So it was 2003.
But 2000 is really we've been together ever since then.
That's a long time to be together
to maintain a level of intimacy, to keep things interesting,
amidst raising children, building businesses,
all the like, most relationships don't make it,
people drift apart.
And we're both here to grow.
And we have done that.
We've both grown as individuals and as a community
and there are aspects of our respective growth trajectories
that have moved us apart.
Like when we first started this thing,
we were doing a lot of stuff together.
We made the cookbooks together.
It was all about the food.
And not to say that that isn't still fundamental
to kind of our mission,
but we found our respective niches in different lanes
and have supported each other in pursuing those things.
And I think on some level
it's made our relationship a little bit healthier
because we have things that we care about
and we can support each other in,
but because we're not as in mashed
or as integrated as we were before,
it then requires a lot more attention and work
to make sure that our relationship
doesn't become transactional and just about logistics
and what is the calendar say and who needs to go where,
and who needs to get picked up.
And we've gone through extended phases of that.
I'm not saying that we're perfect in any regard with that.
Like I think that our intimacy suffered
particularly through the pandemic
as a result of survival instincts
and just getting through the day
and making sure that everyone was where they needed to be.
But my birthday and the date that we had
has really been a powerful reminder
to help us return to that special place
and remember that everything that we're doing
is about our intimate relationship at all, comes from that.
That is the crucible pond,
which we're able to kind of do what we do in the world.
Yeah and I had just come back from teaching
my sacred sexuality retreat in North Carolina Boone.
Yeah, well, I talked about on the podcast a couple of times
about the fact that we've been together all these years
and that there has to be an evolution.
Like we have to go to the next thing.
We're not gonna just be Rich and Julie
in the way that we were static
and we were never static, but, you know, in that version,
it has to keep evolving.
And I think the retreat was amazing.
It was beautiful.
We had a beautiful group of people
and very profound experiences.
And it's really a spiritual mission.
It's a spiritual activation
into the embodiment of all that you are.
And then understanding that you can use this sacred force,
this sexuality as a creativity or a spiritual force
to shift things in your life, to create things,
to heal the planet, to change the weather,
to heal your body, to do all kinds of things.
And so it was a first off and it was really cool.
It went extremely well.
And one of the things that became clear to me
as I wrapped up this amazing experience
was that, you and I are here for the evolution
and that is the most important thing.
And you have been an are and will always be
one of the most profound human experiences,
probably of all of my lifetimes.
What we have done to--
Top five?
Easily top five.
Okay good (laughs).
What we've done together is profound.
And it's in spite of us.
I mean, you have two individuals
who are extremely different,
like just in our natural orientation,
the fact that we got together,
you were coming out of a marriage.
I was coming out of a marriage with young kids,
and that we were able to go
through this financial collapse this extreme pressure.
It was not a short amount of time.
I mean nine years is not.
It's kind of interesting
that it's nine years of the podcast.
You always say nine years.
And in my mind, my mind, I don't think it was nine years.
Yeah, it was, I think it was 2007,
maybe not 2007 was the slide down.
And then just beginning to poke our selves out,
the head out of the water was probably 2014.
So how many days?
That's seven.
So, and I--
It was a slow slide
and it's a slow crawl out.
Yeah, exactly.
But there's still wreckage.
I mean, we're yeah, exactly.
But I guess I wanted to have said that to you.
I wanted to have plainly express that to you.
And you know, what I told you,
and what I asked of you was to support me
and I gave you my support,
unconditional support for your life experience,
whatever that is,
regardless if it scares me,
regardless if it's not conventional
it's what do you now, what do you need to evolve?
What is next?
And I think we have to be brave enough
if we're gonna be together for this many years,
we have to be brave enough to face what scares us,
what might change in the relationship,
but we don't have to let it die,
or we don't have to kill it,
we can breathe life into it in new ways.
And relationships are changing,
I mean, we're on a completely new frontier
and, you know, I will be with you
till the end of time for whatever it is
that you were up for, even if it scares me.
Yeah. I think that's a powerful
idea and lesson
that disabuses me and anyone who's listening
from the idea that a relationship is ever static.
Whether you've been together for six months or a year
or five years or 21 years, everything is always changing.
Everything is always in flux.
And the human mind
is very good at certain things
and very bad at other things.
And what it's good at is pattern recognition.
And it looks at a pattern and says,
this is the way the world is.
And there's an expectation built into that,
that that pattern will perpetuate or continue.
And if the pattern gets interrupted or broken
or meets an obstacle that becomes a trigger for fear, right?
So it's all about preserving the pattern
and in a relationship
preserving the pattern
may work for a certain period of time.
But ultimately it sounds the death now,
because you're never static.
You're either moving towards greater intimacy
or away from it, away from that intimacy.
And the more you move away from it,
the more kind of cloistered
and isolated you become from your partner.
And then without that sharing piece,
like you're gonna drift apart, right?
So it takes like constant pressure
and constant attention to just maintain it,
let alone evolve it in a positive direction.
And I say that as somebody who's
traditionally not been great at
I wanna just like, it's cool.
Like, we're, it's good.
Like you want it, what movie do you wanna see tonight?
Like, I don't wanna do the work.
I don't wanna always be exerting that pressure.
You're very good at saying, okay, we need sit down,
and figure out what's going on with us right now.
Short of you calling attention to that,
I will allow it like, you know, sort of disintegrate.
To atrophy.
Yeah, exactly.
And so thank you for that
because it is uncomfortable
and those conversations are not easy to have,
but ultimately if we're gonna make it
and we're gonna stay together,
we have to create that space for each other
where we can be honest,
even if it's uncomfortable
and figure out ways to support
our own respective evolutions,
particularly now that we are doing different things.
Like you've got this whole entrepreneurial journey
with SriMu and your teachings
and all these various projects that you're working on.
That don't involve me at all.
And it's very easy for you to just be immersed in that.
And like, I don't even know what's going on.
Meanwhile, I'm over here doing this thing.
And, you know, it's individuated
on a level that it wasn't historically in our relationship.
So it requires much more presence of mind
and attention and care to detail
in order to maintain the level of intimacy
that's gonna keep us together,
particularly as our kids grow up
and ultimately fly the coop and go out into the world.
Yeah, I mean, definitely.
And I think as you mature along the journey it gets harder
because my default is to be in meditation,
doing some ritual, like in some,
and your choice is to be like running up a mountain
or doing a race or something like that.
And that's one of the things that we talked about.
I'm never going to be running a race with you.
Like, that's probably a very unlikely event.
And you're unlikely to be diving into ritual and ceremony
the way that I do.
So how do we commune with each other
and how do we go deeper into who the other person is,
but it takes presence and attention and desire,
and a lot of love and a lot of unconditional neutrality
to be in that space.
Yeah.
We joked the other day that,
so when we go on this date
and you're like, I have things I wanna tell you, right?
And we're sitting there and you're like, first of all,
happy birthday.
(laughs)
And you're like,
but there's this big buildup to what's coming next.
And I'm thinking she gonna breakup with me?
She's gonna say happy birthday
and then tell me she wants to have a different life now?
Like what's going on?
No, it was very emotional.
I was very emotional
because I hadn't been able to talk to you
for a very long time in a very deep way.
Because of all the sort of narrative that is,
that was literally infuses our life
and seeks to separate us.
It seeks to put a wedge right now.
That is the agenda, is to separate us.
And so we have to dig deep to not do that.
And at the end, it's like I know if I left my body,
you would not feel that separation from me.
And I know that if you left your body,
I would not feel that.
And so can we get to what's really real?
Can we leave all this stuff to the side?
And can we get to what's really real?
And just be that for each other.
I mean, as soulmates or partners, or lovers,
if we aren't here for each other at that level,
then what is?
And who is?
And we can make that choice.
So you just taught this retreat on sacred sexuality.
So the first question is
how important is the sexual piece
and kind of ancillary to that
for somebody who's listening or watching,
who is in a relationship,
perhaps a long-term relationship that does feel stagnant,
or they feel like they're struggling
to have that intimate communication channel
with their partner.
How do you counsel somebody
to reconfigure their relationship
or take actions that can get the two people
in better sync with each other?
Well, I feel that it is entirely a solo journey, in fact.
And so I've renamed the word masturbation,
one of the ugliest words in the English language
and it's by design by the way.
So calling it like self communion okay?
And really taking the little snickers.
(laughs)
'Cause I knew you would laugh.
He's laughing.
No, but it's true.
It's like the thing is it's your body, it's your force.
And if we knew it was the most powerful force,
the most sacred force,
how would you treat it if you really understood that?
If you really understood our society
treats it with pornography and violation
and abuses against people.
And it's been vibrating in a very low place
for a very long time.
But I also feel like it is a complete emergence
of something we've never known before.
And so the first thing is to get embodied in your own form.
Do you receive yourself as a divine being?
Do you understand that you are consciousness,
you're a fractal of this great mirror
that's walking through life expressing yourself.
And can you receive yourself with that love?
Because if you can't,
you can't really receive another with that love.
So the workshop kind of went like this.
First of all, we're doing yoga again.
I'm just gonna take this opportunity to mention
that I have the iFIT Series is coming out.
There's four yoga programs that I've done.
They were absolutely amazing to me.
They treated me with such reverence
and freedom and creative support, blew my mind.
I was very touched by this experience,
but anyway, I've done four series.
And so one is about trauma into your treasure.
One is about grief into awareness.
One is about embodiment for immunity.
And one is about living your most heroic life.
So I'm saying that because again,
going back to the foundation,
a core yoga practice is key
to really being able to embody who you are.
And it's just not the same as running.
It's not, it's just not the same.
It's a way to access yourself,
to gain the awareness of the greater you
that is always there.
That is observing what's going on in your life.
And it is profound,
so I would highly recommend finding a yoga practice
and exploring through that.
Then we went back to what's behind me too.
So we just looked at thousands of years on the planet.
Thousands of years ago,
the feminine energy was literally ripped out
of the spiritual history of our planet,
completely annihilated.
And I make the joke that I thought I was a modern woman
'cause I read in Cosmopolitan magazine
that I could have an orgasm, like when I was like 14.
And it's a joke.
Whenever you want.
It's a joke, I mean,
it's like women only got the right to vote
like a minute ago, like this has been the planetary setup.
The good news is that setup is over.
So now we are in a different age.
It's no one's fault.
It's not about being mad at the masculine,
it's about us recalling ourselves
and re-imagining how we are in relationship
and both masculine and feminine existing within us.
So balancing those two energies.
We then did a holotropic breathing practice,
which there's a little taste of this in the iFIT series.
We then walked a spiral that was a technology
that I had sent over from Dom in her
that was activated with this very powerful energy.
So we spiraled in and out of this form that was created
and then we had a fire ceremony in the evening.
And then the next day was about bringing ritual
back into our sexual spaces.
So it was about processes
and drawing energy up into your heart
and infusing your body with the sexual energy
and how to make it a beautiful thing
and how to really take that moment
to make sure that it's reverent
and that it's beautiful.
However, also remembering that the human experience
is the whole spectrum.
So we're not just gonna have sexuality
as an angel in a white robe type of thing.
Like you're allowed to play in the spectrum
of between consenting adults or with yourself,
whatever that is.
I'm not here to tell you what that is,
but I'm saying the intention of going into it,
that this is a sacred force.
And so how will I use it?
How will I treat it?
How will I cultivate it?
How will I interact with it?
And what does it really mean?
And when I do share it with another,
who and in what circumstance,
and in what way will I share that?
If I knew that it was so precious and so amazing.
And then the final thing,
we interact, we did a yoga need that
which is taking your awareness around the body.
Again, I have little snippets of this all
in the iFIT Series.
And then we did a journey into returning to a time
when we all used ritual in our sexual experiences.
And then we did an open eye meditation
on the geometric form of the solar feminine,
which is from the template Jeeva and Juliet Carter.
It's a form that you spin with a light
and you interact with it viscerally with your body.
And the final step was a self-initiation
of each person going in the mirror and meeting themselves
and being blessed and just seeing yourself as divine.
So it's really a spiritual activation of embodiment
and this community it was very beautiful.
They really got a lot out of it
and it's the beginning
because we all have to rewrite
the way that we're going to interact with this energy.
How many dudes were there?
Two.
Two duds.
There were actually three, but one left,
so there was two, yeah.
Two beautiful men, brave powerful men.
Amazing and we really gave them a lot of love
at the very beginning
for having the courage to come and--
Yeah. I mean, the reason I ask is because
these modalities or this sensibility
is inherently very feminine, right?
So I'm just imagining
somebody who's listening to this,
like a woman who's listening to this
and says I'm gonna try this.
I'm gonna go home and I'm gonna get my husband
or my boyfriend or whoever it is and sit them down
and I'm gonna try to create ceremony and ritual around this,
and then imagining the guy being like, what is going on?
Like what are you talking about?
You know, so there's a barrier there I think
in a traditional sense with the kind of normal dude
where even broaching this subject
becomes challenging and trepidatious
because it's unchartered territory for the average male.
Definitely, but the thing is,
is that the average dude
is in a state of awakening right now.
And so things are really changing.
And I had talked to a lot of people
in various places where I've traveled
and I had a lot of people share with me
that they were experiencing the same thing,
that they were understanding
that the sexuality that they had been experiencing
was not gonna work for them anymore.
Like they were wanting more
because none of us wants molestation and violation.
And as I was saying, like 92% of my clients
have been sexually molested as children, both men and women.
So it's actually not that rare.
So there's this tapestry of trauma
that's like sprinkled,
the lattice work of all of this for a lot of people.
And it's quite common.
And then you have
right now out in the aftermath of me too,
which thank God, I have me two stories that would shock you.
So there's no one more happy than I am
that that was brought out to light.
And then you also have a lot of men and a lot of individuals
who are just unclear about how to proceed.
And then also like our boys were telling us
that this generation is the least sexual generation
in like 100 years or something like that.
So everything's up for transformation.
I mean, you got gender fluidity.
It's not just heterosexual couples, it's for everyone.
And the point, the point for me is
I've been in a lot of relationships
and I've been in love quite a few times.
You're my favorite, but I'm (laughs)--
I'm crestfallen to hear that.
Top five.
I'm gonna judge you based on your past relationships.
Top five honey.
Top three?
Well you said top five all time,
like throughout all timeline.
I know but now I'm going for top three.
You're so competitive.
That's the thing you wanna be number one.
No, of course.
But my point of me sharing this
is that I realized after about the fourth time,
I think when we're young and love
we think that the person we're in love with
is exuding the love to us,
and that is what we're feeling.
But in my experience, the love is coming from you.
So you own your love.
You're just reflecting it off of another individual
because you'll find when you're in love again,
that you're like, oh there's that love.
It feels exactly the same way.
And so again, it's this cultivation
of embodiment of understanding first
that you are divine
and just worthy and cherished and loved
and celebrated for who you are.
And then that your sexual energy is yours
and nothing and no one has the right to interfere with that.
And it is also your greatest power.
And if you knew that, how would you use it?
How would you choose?
It's your choice.
I'm not telling you how to use it.
Yeah, I think it's instructive to think about it
as an exchange of energy and a powerful one at that, right?
So you are in relationship with another human being
and there's gonna be this exchange of energy.
Like, how do you want that directed?
Because however you choose to direct it
is going to have impact and power, no matter what.
So putting some intentionality and consideration into that,
I think is a powerful exercise.
Definitely.
So, well, welcome to the sacred sexuality chamber.
I know, and I'm excited for this.
iFIT course to come out.
We should say for people that don't know
iFIT is like this digital platform, subscription service
for all manner of health, wellness, fitness programming,
it's sort of like Peloton,
they have like a treadmill and a bike
and stuff like that that have these big screens
and when you subscribe,
you're able to access like this library of stuff.
And what's amazing about this company
is the level of intentionality and production quality
that they're bringing to this program.
I mean, when they came to our house
to film this series with you,
I mean, it was like we were filming a feature film.
I mean, the crew, how many people were in this crew?
I mean, there were multiple cameras
and a crew of like 40 people and like a whole wardrobe.
I mean, it was unbelievable.
And then you went to Italy and filmed there as well.
Like there were multiple locations, international,
they spared zero expense.
And I can't wait to see the finished product
because so much went into it and it's finally coming out.
Yeah it was a beautiful experience.
I mean, they really, really,
I just have to really emphasize
how amazingly conscious they were
and loving and creatively supportive.
And, you know, I had like five cameras
and when I began this series,
they gave me a dozen roses.
When I ended, they had a dozen roses
and I was in every shot.
So I shot four series back to back,
which is quite physically challenging.
How many days?
It was five days shoot.
So there were five days and I did four series.
Yeah five days at our house
and then we went to Damanhur
and we filmed inside the temple.
So I had a cinematographer, actually two
who came and were with me
and we filmed all in the temples of Damanhur
and it'll be intercut with the pieces.
And they have these mirrors
where your instructor ends up in the mirror.
And the thing that I, why I wanted to do it
and why it was so important to me
was to be able to document these yoga practices
that I teach on retreat.
And I know that they're transformational,
they've been transformational for me.
Just one of these series could shift your life
like drastically.
And they honored me.
They said, do it exactly the way you wanna do it.
They weren't trying to edit me at all.
Are you sure?
And like, are you sure?
'Cause I have the spaceship coming.
No I did yeah, I really did it.
I mean, it's really what I teach on retreat
at Plantpower Italia for all of you
who wouldn't have the opportunity to go there,
or just that just wouldn't work for you,
check out the iFIT series,
because it really is a full encompassing experience
where you'll get a taste of like some Shee Kong,
some yoga nidra, some holotropic breathing,
definitely some activations and prayers and meditation
like I do on my spiritual mentorship platform, Water Tiger.
And then just really great, awesome.
So again, they have the titles,
which is what they're sort of designed around.
And you know, one of the things that many of us are facing
are the exit and transitions of our loved ones.
And if we haven't been open to spirituality
often it is that kind of loss
that if we're lucky, may render us on our knees
and allow us to seek what is beyond this life.
And I spoke to a very dear friend of mine
and an interior design client
and dear friend of my mom's, my beautiful Rosie
and her daughter died suddenly recently
and she's just devastated,
like the grief is just crushing her.
And you know, this is a very real thing
that we are going through right now.
And I will tell you,
the yoga practice will give you shelter through that.
It will help you and guide you through your own process.
And as I said at the very first podcast
at the beginning of the pandemic,
what we can do in this very tender moment
of many exiting is not waste their exit.
So if they're providing you that experience of tenderness
and of being really split open to your core,
we can choose to dedicate that to the expansion
and use the gifts that they've given you
to really, really evolve and expand.
And you will see them again,
you will, if it' your desire you will see them again.
We are eternal life forms.
So there is just a change of form
and we need to cultivate this connection to this truth.
When you were sharing that,
I was thinking about those extraordinary photographs
that our friend Magdalena was sharing on Instagram
of her mother passing recently.
Yeah so Magdalena is the photographer
that shot Rich and I for Human Shift and she's from Poland
and she had a relationship,
has a relationship with her mother
that is just one of soulmate,
like such a close, amazing relationship,
and also with her father.
But being this extraordinary photographer,
she documented her mom's illness
all the way up until her transition.
And the photographs are powerful.
There's one photograph of Magdalena
actually in the bathtub washing her mother.
And it's this connection between child and mother
and the lens of death and really becoming old
and how Magdalena was able to just celebrate
and embody and love her mom through all the phases.
It is truly a beautiful, beautiful love story
that she has documented.
Magdalena Wosinska is her last name.
She's an unbelievable photographer, she's super cool.
You can find her on Instagram at Magda Wosinska Studio.
Her photographs are amazing.
Brilliant, amazing human.
All right, well, let's switch gears a little bit.
I do want to talk about the latest happenings with SriMu
but before we do that,
we both have a couple of books that we wanted to share.
You brought three books there.
No you go first.
Yeah well I'll share, I'll go first.
People always ask me, like, what are you reading?
What should I read?
To be a podcaster is to perpetually have homework
and I'm always reading books for upcoming guests.
So the vast majority of my reading,
I had this impulse to say unfortunately,
not unfortunately
I have the good fortune of reading many books
for authors that I'm hosting on the show,
which is fantastic,
it just doesn't leave a lot of room for reading other books.
But I do want to share a couple
because
they have impacted me
and also because part of the thing with the podcast
is always trying to kind of get ahead and bank episodes.
A lot of guests make themselves available for publicity
because they have a book coming out
and they do that in the two or three weeks
leading up to the book coming out.
But as we bank episodes,
it means that oftentimes these episodes don't come out
until quite a bit later.
And so I wanted to share a little bit of love
with some of these books
because they've recently come out
and perhaps it would be good if you read them
before the guest appears on the show.
The first of which being "The Book of Hope",
which was written by my friend Douglas Abrams,
who was a classmate of mine at Stanford.
And he wrote it in partnership with Jane Goodall.
It's an unbelievable read
and the second in this global icon series that he's doing,
where he shares space with amazing people
and engages them in long form conversation
and ends up creating a book out of it.
The first of which being "The Book of Joy",
which was the result of conversations
that he had with Bishop Desmond Tutu and the Dalai Lama,
and that became this massive bestseller,
and he's made this documentary about it
that's hopefully coming out soon.
The second being this Book of Hope,
which is about Jane Goodall's life through the lens of hope
and her fidelity to this idea of hope,
being an engine for positive change
as somebody who has lived as an activist
and an advocate for change her entire life.
And it's really powerful.
We had a beautiful conversation, Doug and I,
the other day on the show
with the episodes not coming out for a little while.
So I think it would be great
if everybody picked up that book and read it
before Doug appears on the show.
So that's my first recommendation.
The second is "The Proof is in the Plants"
by my buddy Simon Hill.
Simon.
Simon is the host of The Plant Proof Podcast.
I'm sure many of our listeners also enjoy his show.
He has, I think
the best plant-based focused podcast in the space.
He lives in Bondi Beach in Sydney, Australia.
So when I was in Australia a couple of years ago,
I spent a lot of time with him.
He also has a restaurant called Eden in Bondi,
which is like the best plant-based restaurant in Sydney,
arguably one of the best
plant-based restaurants in the world,
at least that I've had the good fortune of eating at.
He's also just a beautiful, very heart-centered guy
who is steeped in the nutrition science
and has a very kind of compelling
but gentle way of talking about nutrition
that I think is really helpful to a lot of people
and he put it all in this book.
"The Proof is in the Plants",
which is a very plant centric plant forward,
take on why we should be eating more plants in our diet
without getting into jingoistic,
kind of labeling about what you call your diet
or don't call your diet.
So for anybody who is interested in that kind of nutrition,
deep dive, definitely pick up the book.
It's been out in Australia for a while,
but it just arrived on our shores more recently.
So that's my second one.
The third one is "Forward" by Andrew Yang.
Andrew being of course the guy
who ran for president in the 2020 election
and more recently had a mayoral bid in New York City.
He came on the podcast last week
and I think that episode's going up in two or three weeks
or something like that.
We had a really fun conversation.
I think he's a really original thinker
when it comes to politics
and kind of shaking up the status quo
with interesting creative ideas
about how we could uproot some of our systems
that aren't working.
And I really enjoyed that conversation.
I think his book is really fun
regardless of what your political affiliations are.
It's really not about partisanship,
it's really about ideas
and I just found him to be really engaging and fresh.
So that might be another one to pick up.
Awesome, love those.
What do you got?
What do I got, something quite different.
I wanted to give a shout out to Anita Kopacz
for her debut book called "Shallow Waters".
Anita and her husband Sheldon
and children's Saidi, Tila and Mayan
were part of our homeschool experiment back in the day,
and they are just magical and full of light.
And Anita is an amazing priestess and healer and shaman
and she was raised,
her mom was connected to the mystical arts of life
and Anita is a light to the world
and she has just written this book
about the African mysticism
and connection to spirituality.
Michael Beckwith says "Shallow Waters"
personifies the diasporic journey of African spirituality.
This story is a powerful call
for people to return to their roots.
And the little intro it says
in this stirring and lyrical debut novel
that your Yoruba diety of the sea,
Yemaya is brought to vivid life
as she discovers the power of black resilience,
love and feminine strength in antebellum America.
So I'm really just so happy for Anita
and love her so much.
And this is a family that is very, very dear to us
and very much a part of our journey
through raising the kids.
Then I have Lauren Duke's debut memoir,
which is called "Shithouse".
And I met Lauren--
It's the best title.
It's such a great title.
I met Lauren actually at this leaving tea retreat
that I chuffed for in Telluride.
And we ended up traveling back together to LA,
just met and we had a very long time to talk
'cause we flew and then we drove together in the car.
And Lauren has just an amazing experience
of being raised in a very,
I would say colorful, eccentric upbringing
that is full of sort of shenanigans
and her dad being in prison.
And she told me a story
where she actually stole cars with him
when she was 15 years old.
(laughing)
Lauren is unapologetically vibrant
and has just gone on a journey through yoga.
So she's the founder of Gather in Encinitas.
And she's an amazing anusara yoga teacher
and just a really real individual.
And we, like I said, we had a long time together
and when she was describing the book to me
it reminded me of the memoir "Glass Castles".
And I love that memoir.
And I think I mentioned it before
because like Rich and I
were kind of similar to the characters
like if it had just been dial clicked
like a little more to the extreme,
but they ended up making a movie of that book
and I have really high hopes for "Shithouse".
I think it's an amazing lively story
of this extreme experience of life and the constriction
and someone who really journeyed her way into an evolution.
And it's also sort of part self-help so it's prescriptive
where "Glass Castles" was just more of a drama.
So anyway, I'm excited for Lauren for that.
And then I got to meet Joanne in real life
and she actually brought her book, "The Korean Vegan".
She is just such a dear human being
so much love and creativity
that the photographs in this book are just exquisite.
I mean, just look at the cover image.
Like I just can't wait to dive into sort of learning
how to create some of these Korean sauces
and lemon and marinades and different processes.
So anyway, it's a beautiful, beautiful book
and Joanne and I are gonna do some fun stuff together,
but she's just, she's a doll.
She's incredible.
The book debuted number three
on the New York Times bestseller list.
Only number three in The New York Times.
In the how to like sort of self-help category
like behind "Atomic Habits"
and then some book about dogs
that was number one.
I don't get that, but I guess people love dogs.
But congratulations to Joanne for that,
it really is a beautiful creation.
And what's cool is that
she is just at the beginning of this amazing journey.
I mean, she only started her tic toc
at the beginning of the pandemic.
So she's in the starting gate
of what is certain to be a brilliant career
and I can't wait to see what she has in the works
and what she's going to be creating.
I mean, she only just walked away from her law firm job,
like a couple of weeks ago.
It's very exciting.
Now she has the bandwidth and the ability
and the resources and the support
and the time to create to her highest potential.
And I have no doubt that we're gonna be seeing a lot of her.
Definitely and I need to give her a shout out
of just being my inspiration.
She showed me how I could present
just my awareness
and the things that I care about spiritually
combined with my food.
So I've just done like a first series of little videos.
I'm inspired by the unbelievable "Korean Vegan".
Her genre busted waves, melding story with food.
So thank you, Joanne you're beautiful.
All right, well speaking of food,
what's going on with SriMu
we have this beautiful presentation in front of us.
So it's the holidays you guys.
Amazing vegan cheese?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So the main thing is just wanted to announce
that we now have four products.
So we have our Sacred Ultra box,
which is four age wheels of cheese
that come in this amazing box.
And then we also have smoked almond shutter,
which is called bonfire it's at the end of the board.
It's that ball.
It's not your grandma's cheese ball.
And then we have fresh mozzarella
that ships in salted water that comes in the jar.
So this is your amazing a gift pack.
We are doing one time boxes
for any of our offerings for the holidays,
and we're doing a code on every single offering
for Rich Roll Podcast listeners.
So it's just RRP22.
And we're giving you 22% off on any product.
Can I do that on your show?
Yeah, I think so, you go to srimu.com.
S-R-I-M-U.com.
And then there's a coupon code, RRP22.
So then you get 22% off.
Exactly.
I like the one box thing.
I mean, that's something I'm sure you guys hear a lot of,
like, why do I have to subscribe?
Can I just get a box?
Yeah, yeah, no, you can do one time boxes.
The other thing that we have is
the two wheel is in that thin little amazing box there
that's the perfect clutch size.
And you have two variations on that.
So you can customize that box a little.
And then in the third box over there by Rich,
it's both a three wheel and a four wheel.
So those are age wheels
and remembering that you can freeze the wheels beautifully.
You just have to take them out
about an hour before you serve them.
So if you're traveling
and you want to keep your SriMu in perfection,
you can freeze.
But anyway, yeah.
So the other thing that I need to mention
is for Thanksgiving.
So we ship on November 15th
because we're a perishable product.
So we can't ship at the end
we have to make sure that it makes it to you.
So you have to get your orders in by November 15th
for a Thanksgiving holiday spread.
And then for Christmas and Hanukkah spread,
you have to get your order in by I think it's the 14th
is the last ship date of December.
And will that code survive through the holidays?
It will survive,
we will look for you and we will make it survive.
And is that apply for subscriptions also
or just one box?
No, it applies for everything,
and you can subscribe and also get 22% off as well.
So how many different cheese products or flavors--
Well, we're looking at there on the board
we have the Gold Alchemy,
which is the turmeric pepper infuse wheel
that tastes like a ham cheese and mustard sandwich.
It is crazy when you eat that,
like when I first had it, I was like,
what is this tastes like, I know this taste
and I couldn't place it.
And who was it who figured that out?
Becka.
Yeah and then you're like, once you hear
it's like a ham and cheese sandwich with mustard
you can't unremember that
and when you eat it, you're like,
it's crazy how much it tastes like ham and cheese sandwich.
Yeah, it's amazing.
I mean, it's becoming in our tastings and events,
it's becoming really one of the top flavors actually.
Then right alongside of that, we have Spire,
which is our spirulina infused, very lively,
there's a lot of tastes in this
and it's kind of blue inspired, but better than blue.
And then we have a birdie, which is cabin bear inspired
it's truffle infused very French,
very, very authentic tasting.
And then the creamy wheel underneath the Spire
is called Elder.
And this is a really mild wheel.
And one of the things that I also want to mention
is we have quite an extensive recipe array
on the SriMu website.
Also, it's gonna be recipes that we're sharing
throughout these videos over the holidays.
But the wonderful thing about SriMu
is that it cuts your prep time down
for an event or for Thanksgiving or for any holiday meal,
it makes the cooking so easy
because you're taking your dish to a five-star level
by simply adding the cheese in at the end,
because it's already aged and already cured
and already has this developed taste.
So Elder is really great to use in cheesecakes,
even in hot chocolate, risotto--
In hot chocolate?
Yeah, can you imagine?
I've never tried that.
Well it's cashew based
so if you're making a natural hot chocolate,
that's not with a milk, you might use some cashews.
So you can use Elder with the cacao and with vanilla
and some kind of sweetener
and it's quite full bodied and beautiful.
And then the other flavor
that is really just neck and neck
with the Gold Alchemy is the Dolce,
and that has coconut in it.
It's creamier and just has this pure flavor
and a lot of people really, really love that.
So, but in the box,
this is the only box that you can get the fresh mozzarella,
which is really one of SriMu's most profound creations.
And I really encourage you to try it
because it's really next level.
The mozzarella?
So it comes suspended in like a solution.
In water, crystal salted waters.
And these bowls they're beautiful.
And they're great, like they're perfect caprese salad
just fall down on the floor.
Like it's better than mozzarella.
Yeah, I mean, a couple of things,
I mean we eat tons of this stuff at home, obviously,
like we have a whole wine cooler next to our refrigerator.
That's like seven feet tall
that normally you would put wine in
and it's just has cheese wheels in itself.
There's constant experimentation in how to use this.
And the first thing I would say
is that on that prep time thing,
like you see these wheels
and you immediately think like crackers and wine
or something like that.
And certainly it has that purpose,
although it's not a sauce, it can be used almost as a sauce.
Like you kind of weave it into pasta
to make like a fettuccine or something like that.
Like it does have a melting point to it
where it becomes like a creamy sauce when heated
and it just adds that like zing
to anything that is unbelievable.
And the second thing is
for people that haven't tried it yet,
but have some experience with like vegan cheese
or like plant-based cheese,
I don't know about you, but like almost all,
if not, maybe not all, but like the vast majority
of what's available to the public
in this space is pretty fucken bland
and it all kind of tastes the same,
even though there's like, oh here's like Havarti
they all kind of taste the same.
This is not like,
you really have outdone yourself.
This is like art as food in so many ways,
and the flavors are like unbelievable.
And it's always so fun when we have people over
and you share it with them for the first time.
Like their heads explode.
They cannot believe that there is no dairy in this cheese.
It's very fun.
Especially Europeans who have a lot of experience
with like fine cheeses
who go in and they're kind of like,
okay, Julie's gonna make me taste this thing.
I'm gonna have to be nice.
And I don't really wanna say anything.
You know, like that whole experience
and then turning the table on them is always super fun.
It's been really a joy.
I used it all in my temple food
that I created food for 36 people for six nights in a row.
And I made everything in prayer,
everything as a prayer
and the SriMu was in every dish and it just elevated it,
it just like took it over the edge completely.
And the other thing that I want to mention
is that we are launching wholesales.
So we actually have a new line.
I tried a couple of the new flavors the other night.
And what'd you think?
Are we allowed to talk about that?
Yeah, I think so.
The peppercorn one.
It is called Fire.
It's a pepper Jack inspired.
Pepper Jack, that's what I meant.
It has a real nice spicy flavor to it.
I really enjoyed that one.
I didn't try the blue one 'cause it got gobbled up.
Oh everybody was freaking out over the blue.
Everybody seemed to love that one
and I didn't even get to try it.
Yeah, actually yeah, it's called Imagine.
It's literally royal blue.
Yeah, it's very blue, it's beautiful.
So what is in that?
It's butterfly pea powder.
Butterfly pea powder.
Pea powder is what gives it its hue?
That just the color, yeah.
What's the tastes like?
No taste.
It's actually very pure.
But what does the cheese taste like?
Very pure and sort of mild.
But it's just the color, people love it.
We have any of that at home?
We don't have any,
and you guys can't get that in a subscription.
So this is a future thing,
just talking about the future.
These are in development.
We're moving into wholesale and then we--
How many new recipes are currently in development
that are not ready for prime time?
Well we're just doing three into wholesale.
So we're doing everything,
which is like an everything bagel blend.
We're doing the Pepper Jack, and we're doing this Imagine.
So we're launching with those three.
We have 50 in the wings waiting.
So they just have to keep a leash on me
'cause we can't go forward.
But the other thing is, so we're expanding in wholesale
and the other thing that I do need to mention,
which I always am very free and open with sharing,
you know what I'm doing in the next expansion.
So I am now doing a 3.3 million raise with SriMu.
It is a spiritual mission.
I am calling for humanitarians
who want to be part of this mission of global awakening.
We are serving the big Y
to help fund the expansion of the temples
in Damanhur, Italy.
It is an operation in devotion to all life on the planet
and it is something magnificent.
It's going to be an $88 million complex
that houses the indigenous DNA of the planet.
So I'm saying that because I just brought on a board member,
founder member, Tom Lawrence,
who is a podcast listener
who heard me mentioned this on the last podcast
and we've connected and become dear friends.
And he's invested in SriMu and come on the team.
And so we are in the middle of that raise
and just wanted to shout that out
in case anybody feels that this is your calling
and that it is something
that you would like to be a part of.
I'm calling my cosmic family to me,
to join me in this next level experience
of really creating a 100 million dollar company
that will transform into a unicorn in SriMu
and will be used really
for the upliftment of the planet in all ways.
It's a beautiful powerful mission you're on.
(laughs)
The vision is large,
the intention even larger.
So I love it.
It's been really cool to watch you
create this thing out of whole cloth
and instructive and powerful for me,
for you to hold that, hold that vision and execute on it.
It's been really cool and you've built this incredible team.
So it is full speed ahead.
Thank you.
For SriMu.
So for people that wanna check out SriMu
again, S-R-I-M-U.com
and then code RRP22.
Yeah?
Yes.
And if you're digging on Julie,
you wanna learn more about her,
you can check out her Water Tiger Spiritual Community.
You can check out her podcast.
When was the last time you recorded?
Your podcast is great, but you're not consistent.
No, I'm actually less than consistent right now.
And the thing is that I just, I also can't,
I really can't have guests on, it's just not my thing.
Like this is your thing.
Yeah, but that's not what your podcast is.
Your podcast is you doing your thing, your way.
So, I mean, right now
I have a little bit of an inkling in a vision.
If I can craft these cooking videos
and I can merge the message with the cooking videos,
I'm gonna focus in that direction
because SriMu is the big mission right?
And the other thing that I'm doing
is I started writing music.
So I worked with a producer in September
and I have three new tracks for a future music project.
I think it's Instagram, Water Tiger SriMu.
TikTok.
And TikTok.
I am, Joanne's gonna mentor me.
Yeah, she should.
You should just spend a day with her
while she's creating her stuff
and observe how she's doing it
'cause I think you have a lot to say,
and there's a way for you to blend
like the wisdom that you wanna share with the food
in a really beautiful way.
I sent you a Dropbox folder of my videos.
I had Leah sent it to you.
So check it out.
I'll check 'em out.
So not really the podcast right now, sorry guys.
And that's one of the--
But there's an archive there that--
Yeah, huge archive.
For people that are new,
how many episodes do you have sitting there?
I can't remember (laughs).
Hundreds, hundreds.
In any event
you can find everything JuliePiatt@juliepiatt.com.
That's true.
And best to follow me on Instagram.
SriMati S-R-I-M-A-T-I.
All right, I think we did it.
Thanks my love.
How do you feel?
I feel good.
I feel like we got a good flow.
Awesome.
Do you think this worked?
I think so, I hope so.
I am not one to judge.
I'm not in the business.
Are you in neutrality right now?
I'm in, yeah, I'm in, I'm in encouraged neutrality.
Do you see me in my divine essence?
I see all of you.
You're sure?
But do you see me in my divine essence?
I don't know, maybe, I'm working on that.
Okay.
Give me time, patience.
I'm here, all right.
I love you.
Namaste.
(slow serene music)